- So wait, so tell us
about this new version of West Side Story.
- Well, I think it's
really important to note
that it is a re-imagination.
It is so not a remake.
This thing is a masterpiece
and it stands on its own.
- [Kelly] Okay.
But I love that we are
retelling a classic story
for a new generation, you know
Steven Spielberg and Tony Kushner.
I realized that maybe I'm
a little too comfortable
since I just called
one of the greatest directors of all time
by his first name.
- Well, you worked with him for a minute.
I think you probably were
on a first-name basis.
Yeah.
- But he and Tony Kushner
and our casting director Cindy Tolan
paid, you know, great attention to detail.
And there there's such
a beautiful commitment
to authentic casting here.
Every Latino is played by a Latino.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- It's really, it's really cool.
I mean, you can't beat the dance numbers.
Just the music is just, it's
really something to behold.
So I hope y'all will give
it a chance and go see it.
- I love that he did this.
I think it's so cool.
So Rita Moreno originated
the role of Anita,
the character that you played.
So did you get to meet her?
Was that nerve wracking?
- I did.
- What does that mean?
That could go either way for me.
- No, no, no.
She came to, to do kinda
like a show and tell day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Where she spoke to the entire cast
and talked about her experience
with making the '61 film,
et cetera et cetera.
And she's telling this fabulous story
and she says, wait, where is
the girl that plays Anita?
Where is Ariana?
And she was like, niña,
we got some talking to do.
And I proceeded to have
a massive anxiety attack.
I hid under the bleachers
until like 30 minutes later
I finally found the courage to be like,
I'm so sorry I'm so awkward,
but I'm really happy to meet you.
And, and she was like,
I'll tell you anything you wanna know.
And I said, I wanna know
anything you wanna tell me.
And she said, lean into
everything that makes you unique
and you don't need my help.
You've got this.
- Oh, I love that.
That's special. Okay.
I'm so excited to see this and hear it
and experience it.
- I hope you like it.
- I'm gonna love it.
This is right up my alley
- The reviews are bananas.
Like we're our household is
flipping out to see this thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Yeah.